alors là des dossiers qui a été très
présente dans cette cape de cette
campagne c'est le jardin on dévêtent
donc le projet mené par l'actuelle
majorité dont vous faites partie
eric alauzet et anne vignot voulait en
construire 1100 50 logements sur un
cadre de 23 hectares donc on va écouter
maintenant la coprésidente de
l'association du jardin des bêtes qui
vous pose une question qui s'adresse à
vous trois on écoute
bonjour marie hélène parrot de
l'association des jardins d'éveil tu
considérez-vous alors que nous sommes
avons une période de réchauffement
climatique et de fragilisation de la
biodiversité et du vivant qu'il soit
urgent d'urbaniser 23 hectares de
jardins populaires de zones humides
howett
ne serait-il pas plus intelligents a
besoin sont de protéger la nature à cet
endroit de protéger les jardins d'en
construire d'autres et éventuellement
d'installer des nouveaux maraîchers en
bio howett
[Musique]
anne vignot le numéro 2 de votre lit
s'appelle nicolas baudin et les
socialistes c'est lui qui en tant qu
adjoint à l'urbanisme mener ce projet
dévêtent vous aujourd'hui vous en dites
quoi de ce projet vous arrêtez tout vous
construisez autrement vous continuez oui
ce projet il a été pensé il ya plus
qu'un de plus de 15 ans et donc il avait
à l'époque vraiment des objectifs
extrêmement écologistes et pour pour
autant il ya des choses qui se sont sur
imposé c'est à dire la question de la
biodiversité des zones humides etc
donc puisque le débat est posé qu'il est
important et nous avons décidé que des
si nous avons la ville le 28 juin
eh bien nous convoquerons un groupe
d'experts scientifiques ce qu'on appelle
le giec locales pour analyser justement
l'impact du projet tel qu'il avait été
pensé et pourvoir dans leur et à mesure
oui elle avoue fait en quelque sorte
plaisir à la france un saut messieurs
claire arnoux à rien du tout qui est
donc aussi une membre de cette
association willy a réalisé lui pour
cent lors du premier tour c'était pas
possible de mal entendre avec elle entre
les deux tours
j'aurais sur ce bon deal sur ce qui a
été dit il est strictement pas possible
qu'on puisse envisager la question de la
biodiversité l'aménagement du territoire
de l'ensemble du grand besançon qui à
travers le prisme des bêtes
il est très symbolique il est
intéressant et y pose un certain nombre
de questions c'est pour ça que le groupe
d'experts travaillera à partir de ce
dossier là mais pas uniquement sur ce
dossier là quant à l'avenir nos meubles
écologiques sur la question de la france
un soumises jusque là est la question
que vous posez saïd et son cheval de
bataille pendant bien sûr c'est c'était
une valeur symbolique sur laquelle ils
se sont construits d'accord donc
évidemment il pose des questions qui
sont très proches des nôtres
je pense que la plupart des militants de
france a soumis sont très proches du
programme que nous avons construit pour
autant dans l'expression politique telle
qu'elle a été posée à la au soir des
élections
la france est soumise nous a donné des
conditions qui nous ont pas permis de
nous unir
mais je sais combien les militants sont
attachées au travail de l'écologie et
dont contrat ira tous ensemble parce que
de toute façon si on veut transformer la
ville de besançon
il faut qu'on amène un maximum de
personnes qui sont engagées dans cette
question d'écologie qu'il soit sur une
échelle de 10 à 2 ou à 8
elle en entraînera tout le monde eric
alauzet vous les faites vous en pensez
quoi vous fait quoi si vous êtes maire
le 28 juin faut prendre un peu de
hauteur
l'enjeu du développement d'une ville ses
habitants et ses dernières années ce
qu'on observe c'est que toutes les
nouvelles habitations les nouveaux
habitants sur tous à l'extérieur de
besançon stagnation sur besançon
développement en périphérie voyez ce que
ça génère comme transport comme
pollution et ses adjoints s'est
équilibré moitié en ville moitié à la
périphérie
donc on a un gros déficit pourquoi parce
qu'on n'a pas de logement qualitatif
offrira aux bisontins et à prix
abordable
c'est à dire des logements avec des
espaces privatifs extérieur qui ouvre
sur la nature et c'est pour cela qu'il
faut construire je vais je vais revoir
le projet des dettes aussi mais qu'il
faut construire des logements sociaux
privés de tous et la mixité c'est la
miss t il faut absolument construire
howett sinon on renvoie les habitants à
la périphérie
c'est complètement anti écologique
simplement il faut faire un quartier où
la biodiversité ou les jardins sont
présents mais n'a pas mis c'est la
partie de tram sur cette partie là ça
fait 16 millions d'euros
il ya une école qui est prévu à 12
millions d'euros si on fait pas ce
projet là il faut faire un bassin
d'orage pour retenir l'eau si
naturellement avec le projet des bêtes
s'est à nouveau 12 millions d'euros
c'est un gâchis monumental
ouais c'est une aberration écologique de
transformer ces bêtes de ne pas le faire
vivre
c'est une aberration écologique c'est
une aberration économique pour le centre
ville c'est une population qui a acquis
nommé tweet du centre-ville qui vient à
pied en vélo qui consomme au
centre-ville pour l'attractivité de la
vie du centre ville c'est
hyper-important moi je vais le revoir
mais pas avec des experts ça n'apportera
aucun crédit que ni le jugement le
jugement qui sera favorable à la ville
probablement dont vous faites référence
dans cette moyenne
l'action en justice c'est la convention
climat qui se passe au niveau national
fo celi swing les citoyens qui
construisent le projet pas des experts y
aura pas crédible isma noël va donner la
franchement 20 secondes pas plus que
vous avez visé très très en avance les
bêtes vous voulez en faire une thérapie
et sociaux une ferme urbaine exactement
moi je refuse en fait si vous voulez que
besançon soit ce laboratoire de
l'écologie communiste poussant vraiment
à l'extrême gauche comme nous ça nous
est proposée par par madame vidéo
culpabilisant idéologique et c'est un
sujet moi qui me passionne les bêtes
parce que si vous voulez je me suis
toujours opposée vraiment à cette
bétonisation que vous avez porté
conjointement pendant ce mandat et nous
avons un projet vraiment absolument
essentiel sur le cet espace des bêtes
avec cette grande ferme urbaine que nous
allons développer avec des parcours
ludiques légué 30 secondes et bientôt on
va dire guinée sur ces choses là
vraiment le le dos j'ai dit à mes
anciens c'est vraiment un poumon vert je
ne sais pas compter sur les baies est-ce
que je peux apporter un éclairage la
ferme urbaine elle a été installée
nous avons installé dans les serres qui
existe est là et ça j'en suis madame
madame vous allez me laisser terminer
sur la place du 1er mai tombe la barre
vous c'est du béton il avait porté
pendant cette nous avait un il faut
laver l'eau de l'engagement qui est
juste très préconçues très pas du tout
juste moi ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'au concrètement nous avons installé
une micro ferme à cet endroit là nous
avons nous devons réinstaller un certain
nombre de jardins une légumerie c'est
nous qui l'avons mis en oeuvre dans leur
conception d'options de france 2 on va
arrêter sur les cdo des noms mais je
suis désolé on va pas parler que tuer
des bêtes parce qu'il reste de 12
minutes et je voudrais qu'on aborde un
thème qui a été très présent dans